as abortion activists firebomb pro-life
offices and pregnancy centers in
wisconsin in oregon in maryland and
elsewhere around the country the white
house is continuing to insist that the
pro-abortion protests have been peaceful
and should continue
even when they take place at judges
homes
so i know that there's an outrage right
now i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
i actually cannot quite believe what she
is saying here is jen saki saying that
the white house is encouraging the
protests outside the supreme court
justice's homes meaning the protests
that are occurring at those homes
or is she saying that the white house is
encouraging protests outside of meaning
other than or except for the ones at the
judge's homes i hope it's the latter
i've been trying to figure out how to
make it be the latter
but i just don't think it is
i don't think it is because the other
day when saki was asked directly about
the very same protests she refused to
condemn them she said that the she
doesn't have an official government
position on where people protest
i don't think she is saying except for
the judge's homes because today she's
still pretending that the pro-abortion
protests are peaceful despite the
graffiti and the arson around the
country
despite the shrieking mobs outside of
the justices homes where their children
sleep
i don't think
that it's the latter i don't think she's
saying don't go to the judge's homes
because the protests at judges homes
or to influence their decision in this
case are in violation of federal law and
the white house won't say anything about
that i don't believe that gensake is
condemning these protests
because when blm was burning the country
down senior officials in this
administration were raising money to
bail out the rioters
the left is right about one
thing in this whole mess
they are right that we are witnessing a
constitutional crisis
not because the supreme court might
overrule a terrible decision from the
1970s
but a constitutional crisis because the
executive branch is waging war on the
judiciary
the left is willing to tear down the
most fundamental aspects of our system
of government
to defend the killing of babies
and they're not even hiding it i'm
michael knowles that's the michael knull
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jeremiah
shoemaker
who says i've been boycotting target
since they publicly announced in
2015-ish that you can use whichever
bathroom you identify with that the boys
can go to the girls room there i
wholeheartedly agree with the new policy
michael is suggesting i have a name for
it
the standards and norms expression act
or the sane act like if you agree in the
meantime i will continue to not shop at
target that is such
a great idea
this is something that the the left
convinced the conservatives of in the
60s and 70s and then some conservatives
especially more on the individualist
minded side of the the right they really
ran with this and they said you're not
allowed to have any norms you're not
allowed to have any standards just it's
every man can do whatever he pleases at
all times that's not true that's never
been true in american history we have
not only individual rights but political
rights rights as a political community
to say no don't trans the kids no don't
let the grown men go into the little
girls bathroom no no no we actually have
the right to enforce some
sanity i love
your idea for legislation you know what
else i love rockauto.com right now go to
rockauto.com enter knowles in there how
did you hear about his fox you know how
much i love rock auto for a whole lot of
reasons one you're not going to get a
better price anywhere two they got the
same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers three they're a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years four i guess this
really should be number one they've
supported this show for a long long time
this is a really great company not
afraid to stick by this show and stand
by good patriotic american values
but
number five
rock auto is so simple to navigate even
i can do it okay they know their product
they're not selling you stuff they don't
know anything about you go to their
website you get whatever you need for
your car or truck whether you're a pro
whether you're a do-it-yourselfer head
on over right now to rockauto.com get
the brakes shocks carpet wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts or
any other parts you need you could save
20 30 50 off on these products over the
brick and mortar store then write nulls
in their how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
the left is saying the quiet part out
loud specifically the pro abortion left
where there's really not a distinction
these days it used to be that you could
be on the left but oppose abortion
i think that's pretty much gone by the
wayside
it certainly used to be that you could
be a democrat and oppose abortion
that's been gone now
it seems almost entirely gone and it's
it's been extremely
unpopular for 30 years and really
starting with mario cuomo andrew cuomo's
father when he was governor of new york
he invented this idea of i'm personally
opposed to abortion but politically i
support it which doesn't make any sense
at all if you think it's murder then it
should be illegal if you don't think
it's murder then why do you oppose it
if it's just like taking your appendix
out then who cares it's not a big deal
it was always incoherent so so i use
these for the left or the democrats or
the pro-abortion activists
today 99.9 of the time they all refer to
the same group of people and they are
saying the quiet part out loud okay
when jen zaki comes out and she says
yeah we encourage protests outside of
judges homes
she's she's saying what we already knew
the the white house believed
if she misspoke i hope she clarifies it
today but i don't think she did
because the
in in practice the white house has been
encouraging all of these protests
so i'm not surprised that she says yes
we're encouraging them janet yellen who
is the treasury secretary for joe biden
she came out and voiced her opinion on
abortion seems kind of crazy right who
cares what the treasury secretary has to
say about constitutional law and the
bioethical question of abortion who care
well
janet yellen cares and actually she
exposes one of the reasons why corporate
america the kind of big corporate
establishment is so gung-ho on
supporting their employees to go travel
out of state to get an abortion to
support to oppose the overrule of roe vs
wade janet yellen makes the argument
that if we if we have fewer abortions
we're not going to make as much money
i believe that eliminating the right of
women to make decisions
about when and whether to have children
would have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
roe v weighed in access to reproductive
health care including abortion
helped lead to increased labor force
participation
it enabled
many women to finish school that
increased their earning potential it
allowed women to plan and balance their
families and careers and research also
shows that it had a favorable impact on
the well-being and earnings
of of children
if i
wrote a script about the pro-abortion
side
and i
i just wrote exactly what janet yellen
just said her argument for more abortion
and i turned it into a producer in
hollywood they would reject the script
for it being too cartoonishly villainous
they would reject it probably because of
the politics of the script too but they
would reject it because of the writing
because what she just said is is such a
caricature
of an evil villain to say well it is my
opinion that we need to continue to kill
875 000 babies a year because if we kill
fewer of those babies we might not make
as much money and then we won't be able
to buy as much stuff
and then we won't have lots of fun toys
and jewelry and gems and gold and money
we have to kill the babies so we can
have more money that is my reasoned
opinion as the treasury secretary
and then just when you think she's going
to start making some other kind of
that's her primary argument well okay
then she talks about the effect on women
maybe she's just an ideological leftist
too it's really important for women's
well-being
in the labor force
in the labor force for women's
well-being in their earnings potential
so it's just about money you're saying
we need to sacrifice our babies so that
we can make more money
i think that's a bad deal i don't think
we should do that i'm willing to
diminish the gdp of the united states if
it means we don't slaughter upwards of a
million babies a year call me crazy call
me old-fashioned
so it's not even old-fashioned
every evil pagan tribe in the history of
the world has has practiced human
sacrifice to try to grow their riches
okay and the united states right now
with this woman as the treasury
secretary with this government that
we've got in place is doing exactly the
same thing
and they they probably don't even see it
they think that they're they're really
fancy and sophisticated and modern and
they just understand things no they're
doing the same damn thing that awful
tribes have done for all of human
history sacrifice their kids to moloch
so that they can
sacrifice their kids to mammon really
mammon and so that they can have more
stuff
i think that's a bad i think it's pretty
evil
when you really think about it don't you
i think it is but they're saying that
they used to mean that
but they wouldn't say that
and it really throws this into
perspective why is amazon paying for
their employees to go out of state to
get abortions because it helps their
bottom line because it helps amazon make
more money beyond the woke takeover of
amazon or the woke people at tesla
tesla's got the same policy i'm sure a
lot of other corporations are going to
have the same policy beyond the the wild
ideological takeover there's a cold hard
cash capitalist element here too which
is they want to make more money kids are
expensive they cause women to not work
as hard they cause women to take a lot
of time off from work they cause women
to be less reliable in the workplace
because maybe little johnny gets sick
one day and they're not able to come to
that meeting on tuesday and so if you
kill the kid then then if you've got a
much more reliable workforce then you
get much more man-hours out of them
it'll it'll really increase labor
participation that's literally what the
treasury secretary said it's evil it is
i don't throw that word around lightly
it is evil it is hideous it is inhumane
but it's the argument that they are
making explicitly elizabeth warren
lyawatha is really angry too boy oh boy
is she angry her fingers are just
itching for the tomahawk right now
elizabeth warren says that she is going
to fight back tweeted out yesterday i'm
angry
about the potential overrule of roe
and i've got a plan to fight back she's
fighting babies by the way this is
what what does it mean to fight back
against
reducing the number of abortions in
america
what is the object of your fighting the
object is the babies who get to live
warren 2024 let's fight babies i've got
a plan to put those babies in their
place
and she says it she's saying the quiet
part out loud she's got an op-ed in
marie claire uh women's magazine
that i hope elizabeth warren did not
write i've always thought elizabeth
warren is wrong and radical but at least
reasonably intelligent this column that
warren wrote
defending roe v wade and pushing
abortion this might be the single
dumbest column i have ever
read
now
this this column that elizabeth warren
wrote this is not an important document
one very important document is my will
that's why you've got to check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com use
promo code knowles do you know what i
did last week i put the finishing
touches on my will it's sort of a morbid
thing to do but it's a necessary thing
to do think about this you've got your
possessions you've got maybe a house
maybe you've got a car you've got your
children you and you need to know what's
going to happen to all those things
especially the kids after you go okay we
hope that nothing bad happens in any
untimely way but you got to be prepared
okay you've got to do the responsible
thing otherwise you're going to have no
say in what happens to your stuff your
property and your children your family
your most important
asset well we're going to make it super
easy for you epicwill.com you go to
epicwheel.com you use promo code knowles
you can get a will really really quick
okay let epic will protect your family
just like they protect the daily wire
it's so super simple you just secure
your future in as little as five minutes
with a complete will package starting at
119 bucks when you use promo code
knowles you save ten percent
epicwheel.com the most important five
minutes you will spend today
elizabeth warren
i'm angry but determined to protect roe
yes i'm angry she says i'm angry at the
justices i'm angry i'm angry i'm angry
then here's the money line
the minute row is officially gone
more than half the states in the country
are poised to outlaw abortion or
severely limit abortion access if
abortion is outlawed the impact won't
fall equally on everyone wealthy women
will still get safe legal abortions by
flying to another state or even
traveling to another country but the
world will be very different for those
who have the least power
low-income women
women of color victims of incest and
abuse moms already working two jobs to
support their children this far-right
extremist supreme court doesn't care if
americans suffer they are hell-bent on
imposing their views on all of us
did you catch the problem there
did you catch the problem with her
argument
she said
that the minute row is officially gone
more than half the states in this
country will outlaw abortion or severely
restrict it
and therefore this constitutes
the extremist supreme court
imposing its views on all of us
all of us
the majority of whom support outlawing
abortion by the way what the court is
doing is not outlawing abortion as she
explains the court is merely
admitting that there's no constitutional
right to an abortion
and returning the question to the states
and she says more than half of the
states are going to get rid of abortion
or almost get rid of abortion
so it sounds like the court is not
imposing its views on us it sounds like
if anything our views on restricting
abortion go much further than anything
the court might believe actually
ironically it sounds like
what the
the court imposing its views on us
occurred in 1973
when the court created out of thin air a
fake constitutional right to an abortion
when the majority of americans oppose
that right how do i know the majority of
americans oppose that right liz warren
just told me because she said more than
half the states are going to get rid of
it
it was the supreme court in roe versus
wade and then again in planned
parenthood v casey that imposed its
views on us and now it is the supreme
court we hope in dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization that is
going to stop imposing its views frankly
i wish that this court would impose more
views i think there is a very strong
argument that the 14th amendment
prohibits abortion nationwide in the
constitution
john finis and robbie george
conservative legal scholars made a very
compelling argument for that in a brief
that they gave to the court with with
this case the dobbs versus jackson
women's health case
but regardless that's that doesn't seem
to be the opinion that we're going to
get from the court according to the
leaked draft what we're going to get is
the court saying hey we're going to stop
imposing our views on you and you people
can decide whatever view you want about
abortion if california wants it fine if
new york wants it fine and if tennessee
doesn't want it that's fine too
and elizabeth warren is extremely
frustrated because she wants to impose
her views on the majority of americans
who oppose review
it's amazing i said this on the show
yesterday this was the theme of the show
yesterday i said whatever the left
accuses us of they are doing they are
the ones who are doing it and here we
have it yet again another another bit of
proof she goes i won't go through this
whole stupid op-ed but i love this line
she goes for me this isn't about
politics this is personal
is a very very stupid line because
the entire mantra of the feminists
during the 1970s when elizabeth warren
came of age she is very much in the mold
of the 1970s feminists their entire
mantra was the personal is the political
their entire mantra was there's no
distinction between what is personal and
what is political and they had
something of a point there in that
in a self-government the politics is
broadly what we want it to be within the
confines of the constitution
so yes that's true the views that we
hold the way that we want to live the
laws that we want to enforce
our personal opinions about that
become the political opinions in
self-government but it's not political
this is this is personal and she says i
have lived in a world where abortion was
illegal i learned early on that when the
law bans all abortions only safe and
legal abortions will be banned oh oh did
you cool oh that's interesting now do
guns
no do guns elizabeth warren so you're
telling me that in the world where you
ban abortions then you're only you're
just going to get illegal abortions
so what about the world where you ban
guns
you're just gonna get illegal guns right
so why do you keep supporting gun
control
it's a very very
silly argument that she's making here
because
i'll go i'll go with the left for a
little bit i think if you banned guns in
america let's say there were no second
amendment and you just banned guns in
america and you went door to door and
confiscated guns kind of like they did
in australia
i i do think that gun crime and gun
deaths would would plummet i think
that's probably true crime itself might
jump and you might just have people
stabbing you and all sorts of other
things but but if you went door-to-door
and actually collected all the guns and
if that were even possible
yeah i do think i think gun gun violence
would would diminish greatly
but we have a second amendment and we
have a second amendment not just because
the framers of the constitution were
lunatics but because
they they inherited that right from the
english and they inherited that right
because people have a natural right to
self-defense
so they didn't just pluck it out of thin
air it wasn't through their own
unfettered reason it came from tradition
it came from the political community
that they were already in and it came
from
the natural law we have a right
to defend ourselves
so that's why we tolerate there's more
there's more gun violence but it's
because of all of these rights and
because of these political traditions
because it's the right thing to do
there is no similar right to abortion
there is no long-standing
civil right to abortion in american
history there is no natural right to
kill your own babies it's actually
extremely unnatural
and yet elizabeth warren uses this
argument for abortion she doesn't use it
for guns it's very silly she says i
lived in a world in which women bled to
death from back alley abortions a world
in which infections complicated women's
futures on and on and on uh
the last point i want to make on this is
elizabeth warren did not live in that
world
she did not she is being extremely
dishonest here she is parroting the same
old line that the abortion movement has
parroted for 50 years more than 50 years
which is that before roe versus wade in
the years right before it thousands of
women were dying every year from back
alley abortions that's not true
that's that's just not true we know how
many women died from back alley
abortions the year before roe versus
wade 39
not 39 000 not 3 900
39.
we have these statistics from
the government we have these statistics
from
pro-abortion organizations do you know
how many women died that year from
legal abortions
24.
so this is actually even another knock
on elizabeth warren's stupid argument
she's saying that the illegal abortions
were so much more dangerous than the
legal abortions they weren't when you
consider the number of states where
abortion was legal and illegal the rate
of death between for legal and illegal
abortions was roughly the same
the illegal abortions were not
substantially more dangerous than the
legal ones
and that was 50 years ago and still it
was 39 women and 24 women
that's those are the numbers that we're
talking about here
okay
just a total lie where did the thousands
of women number come from it came from
dr bernard nathanson who was an
abortionist who was one of the leaders
of the abortion rights league nae rao
and he admitted in his memoir he just
made it up he just made it up
and she's making it up to and she's
really really angry and she's shrieking
and she's screaming and she's crying and
the libs are attacking pro-lifers all
around the country and going and scaring
the supreme court justices and scaring
their little kids at their homes because
they know they don't have a single
argument they don't have one
not one single argument
i mean i went on this little thought
experiment yesterday
because
the pro-lifers are winning right now but
the pro-lifers are are
we're stuck in the debate i think we're
winning politically i think people have
come over to our side but in terms of
the actual debate you're sitting there
having an abortion debate i think a lot
of times people just spin their wheels
and it's because the debate focuses
entirely on rights
okay
it just writes rights rights the rights
of the baby to live the right of the
mother to have bodily autonomy and you
just debate all of the different rights
and some of the most famous arguments
for abortion involve these crazy thought
experiments about rights one of one of
the most famous arguments is that you
wake up one day and you find out you're
plugged into a dialysis machine with the
world's greatest violinist
and you were kidnapped in the middle of
the night it was determined that your
kidneys are the only kidneys that can
help this violinist survive and so you
were plugged into a machine with the
violinist and uh if you unplug yourself
the violinist is going to die
and but if you leave yourself plugged
into the violinist for nine months
then
the violinist will get to live do you
have an obligation to stay plugged in
for nine months or do you have the right
to remove the
machine this is considered one of the
the great most probably most popular
arguments for abortion it's a very silly
argument and it's a very stupid argument
but it did get me thinking about a
different how can we how can we shake
ourselves out of this this debate on
abortion where it's just about rights
rights rights rights rights because the
libs love to talk about rights my
politics does not begin from the
perspective of rights i don't think that
we're born as free-floating atoms in
outer space who just have rights and
entitlement i think that we are born
first with obligations with duties with
loyalties responsibilities to our
families to our community and to our god
so i have a different experiment
let's say you wake up one day you open
your door and on the doorstep there is
a dirty filthy rotten bum i'll get to
this experiment in just one second first
though starting this friday you can send
in voicemail bags yes that's right send
a voice memo to my mailbag we will play
it on the show get your voice heard on
the michael knowles show i send those in
we're very excited to hear from you also
if there's one thing that you know about
me it's this
i never turned down an opportunity to
kick back smoke a cigar and talk
politics with my friends that's right
you
should not turn down such an incredible
opportunity either
that is right it is time for another
backstage live june 29th at the historic
ryman auditorium in downtown nashville
tennessee this is your chance to get in
on all the smoke-filled fun and
festivities join me ben shapiro matt
walsh andrew clavin and the daily wire
god king jeremy boring for our biggest
live event of the year tickets go on
sale thursday may 12th at 10 a.m central
for daily wire all access members only
12 hours later they go on sale for the
general public if you are not an all
access member do not miss out head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe and
become an all access member today
daily wire backstage live ryman
auditorium nashville june 29th see you
there we'll be right back with a lot
more
imagine for a second that you open your
door one day and there sitting on your
doorstep is a dirty filthy rotten
disgusting bum
and this dirty filthy rotten disgusting
bum
is
really really thirsty
he's dying of thirst his lips are
chapped he's you can tell he's she's on
the brink of death
you have water in your house
maybe bottled water maybe just a tap
maybe just a spigot on the side of your
house
do you have an obligation to give that
filthy dirty rotten disgusting bum some
water
i think you do
let's take it even a little bit further
you've got this filthy dirty rotten
disgusting bum he's out there and he is
dying of exposure it's not just that
he's cold it's not just that he's
you know would like to sit by your fire
he is on the brink of death
and you're living in the country
and there's no one around you're not
you're not living in a high-rise in the
city you're living in the country
there's no one around for miles even if
you call the police even if you call an
ambulance or something they are not
going to get there in time to save this
guy from dying of exposure do you have
an obligation
to take him into your home for just a
little bit
just a few hours just until someone else
can get there to save his life
i think you do
now it's your water
it's your shelter it's your home
you could say
these are my things this is my water
this is my house it's mine to give or
withhold as i please and i choose it's
it my right to withhold it
you could do that and you could let the
bum die but i strongly suspect that you
would have the sneaking suspicion that
there's something wrong with that that
you you actually
i know it's just wrong
don't you that's the suspicion that i
would have
now imagine
that we're not talking about your
doorstep but we're talking about your
womb
now imagine we're not talking about a
filthy dirt and dirty rotten disgusting
bum but a little baby
okay the
analogy actually is not precise because
abortion does not just involve
withholding something like nutrients
from the baby it actually involves going
in and poisoning the baby and then
dismembering him in the body so it's but
let's just for the sake of the abortion
supporters argument let's just pretend
for for a moment that abortion is more
like eviction
than like murder okay let's just pretend
do you have an obligation
to provide
shelter for that baby if the baby is
there and it's a life or death question
do you have an obligation to provide
sustenance for that baby
for your baby
you could say look it's my body
my body my choice you could say hey look
it's my nutrients mine to withhold or
give
but i think we all suspect that there's
something kind of wrong with that now
if
the dirty filthy rotten disgusting bum
who you don't know from adam
has some legitimate claim
on the water in your house
has some legitimate claim on you
has some legitimate claim on
you saving him or you you
in some way offering of yourself to save
him if the dirty rotten gross disgusting
bum who's probably lived a completely
dissolute life has that claim
certainly we should be able to say that
your your own baby has at least as much
claim
this
scenario really bothered some people
when i floated it yesterday on social
media and it bothered some people
because it's coming at the abortion
issue from a completely different
standpoint than we are used to coming at
it from it it's actually coming at
politics from a completely different
standpoint than we are used to coming at
it from
not just that the left is used to coming
at it from but the right too because
we're all stuck in this liberal
rut of talking about rights rights
rights rights rights rights in the
abstract floating in free space with
these crazy hypotheticals about
violinists being attached to us in a
hospital bed
but i'm not talking about a wild crazy
out of out of the ordinary hypothetical
i'm talking to you about something that
really could happen you actually could
have a derelict show up to your door not
saying it's likely but it could happen
and you might be living in the country
and there might not be help and you
might you actually could be called upon
to do this and you would know despite
not having reasoned through it and
thought about it in some long
philosophical tract you would just know
instinctively that you should give the
bum water and that you should maybe even
take him in for a couple hours until he
can get some help you just know that you
know that deep down and as much as you
try to reason yourself out of it and
convince yourself that that's not true
you know that it is true okay
all the more so it is true about
abortion and i think
frankly even beyond the abortion
question
a lot of our political problems and
divisions
would be
greatly improved
if we would just stop for a second
thinking of the entire world and
ourselves and our community as these
ideological abstractions and if we stop
thinking about politics entirely about
what we're entitled to and what we have
the right to do start thinking about
what is my obligation
what is my duty
we used to understand this
conservatives certainly understood this
even democrats jfk asked not what your
country can do for you but what you can
do for your country
help out lend a helping hand it's not
the idea that the moral order imposes
certain obligations on us and we don't
just have the right to do whatever the
hell we please at any given time
that's that's not how we think anymore
now we just think about me me me me and
and and it leads people to absurd places
there is a leftist right now
who just attacked another pro-life
women's group uh this happened at 10 pm
on saturday night
this leftist attacked the concerned
women for america and he did that by
showing up to their
headquarters to their office screaming
yelling flipping them off and then
urinating on their building
exposing himself and urinating on their
building the head of the cwa says
attacks on our employees and our
building will not deter concerned women
for america from standing up for women
and for babies we will not be bullied we
will not back down and we will never
ever stop fighting to protect human life
if you are
a grown man there's video footage of
this by the way if you are a grown man
who shows up and urinates on a
women's organization's building
and screams and yells and shrieks
something has probably gone wrong in the
way you're thinking about things if you
are an adult and you march to a
residential neighborhood to scare a
judge's children
because you don't like a ruling that the
judge may hand down
something
has gone wrong with the way you're
thinking about politics if you think
that the most sacred right that you have
as an american
is
to kill a little baby
no matter all the different
something
has gone wrong with your way of thinking
okay there was a wonderful response to
some of the left-wing protests in
sam alito's neighborhood so you've got
all these crazy leftists chanting change
the ruling you know trying to influence
this judge's opinion and
one of sam alito's neighbors instead of
going out and yelling and shrieking at
the protesters he decided to just sit at
his piano and play a hymn
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hear them screaming and
shrieking and going up and down the
residential neighborhood and then you
just hear this me you don't even see him
just hear him inside his home i guess
he's got the window open playing tis so
sweet to trust in jesus
who do you want to be who do you want
who do you think has the better grasp on
reality the crazy shrieking people with
all sorts of
colorful hair and angry clothing and
shrieking and yelling and crying
on the street or the man sitting in his
piano playing a nice hymn of gratitude
to so sweet to trust in jesus it's
obviously the man
we should all be this guy this is the
way to do it
he is standing firm he's not fleeing his
house he's not getting out of town he's
not running away to some hotel he's
standing firm
he's not throwing sam alito his neighbor
under the bus no he stays just he's
there but he is serene
okay he is he is willing to take it he's
not afraid of the mob he's not he's just
going to play tis so sweet to trust in
jesus because
it is
he
and the protesters have very very
different worldviews
his view which is christianity
used to be the public view of the united
states until very very recently
i know sometimes people say we are not a
christian nation but that's not true we
are obviously a christian nation the
people who founded the country were
almost all christians at the
public ceremonies the public orations
the ethos the founding documents they
all
speak to a christian worldview
what the protesters believe in is
secular liberalism leftism that's their
religion it's private and it's public
and they want the public religion of the
united states to be
secular leftism there's a town in brazil
travel with me for a second down to
south america there's a small town in
southern brazil
that just constructed a gigantic statue
of jesus
a statue that is even larger than the
famous christ the redeemer statue in rio
this town is encantado it's a town of 23
000 people in brazil
and they just unveiled the statue statue
christ the protector on april 22nd it
was funded by a local volunteer
organization they spent obviously a lot
of money to build this statue i love it
this really matters why does this matter
this matters even if you're not a
christian okay this matters if you are
just a normal sane person who doesn't
like the way the left has turned this
country
because what this statue represents is
public christianity there is going to be
public belief there is going to be
public ritual okay
i think i think we all get that now a
lot of cultural conservatives have been
saying this for 50 years and
usually just until we're blue in the
face and it doesn't go anywhere but
people are beginning to see that
with the we have public rituals all the
time we have pride parades
now it's like pride quarter of the year
it used to be pride day then pride week
then pride month
now it's like pride three months
we have drag queen story hour is a kind
of public ritual we have public saints
that we venerate like saint george floyd
and others we have this kind of public
role we have the the maxims and the
dogmas of the public religion like
tolerance and diversity and equity and
inclusion right we have all of this
stuff
which religion do you think has given us
the better country
public leftism public liberalism
or public christianity obviously public
christianity you would want to live in
the country that has public christianity
whether you're a christian whether
you're a protestant whether you're
catholic whether you're a jew whether
you're a muslim whether you're an
agnostic atheist normal person who
doesn't want to trans the kids and burn
the country down every six months
if you are any of those things you will
prefer
the country with public christianity so
let's do it okay let's let's drop the
charade let's stop pretending that there
is some neutrality that this was the
the last 50 years there was this
experiment that the left proposed and
the right-bounded hook line and sinker
that somehow the country's going to be
completely neutral and not take a
position on anything that's why we've
got to kick the bible out of schools in
the mid 20th century that's why we've
got to kick prayer out of schools prayer
out of the public square that wasn't
true from the beginning of this country
we had we had all of those things from
the beginning of this country until very
very recently and coincidentally when we
lost all that stuff and when we exalted
liberalism everything went to hell in a
handbasket so maybe it's time
to turn around even if it's not even for
your personal belief do it for the good
of your political society
now
there is beyond the cultural issues
there is a lot
going on here that is uh just
structurally messed up and i'm not i'm
not even talking about the
the cultural institutions the social
institutions or the schools i'm talking
about the the underlying economy we
opened up the show talking about janet
yellen saying how we we need we need
more abortion so that we can make more
money the economy is relying on abortion
there's obviously a big connection
between the social issues and the
economy but people are not feeling very
good about the economy right now
inflation fears are near record highs
record highs americans inflation fears
are at a near record high in april uh
consumers are expecting the price of
everyday goods to stay elevated in the
coming years according to a key federal
reserve bank of new york survey
published on monday so you know on this
show we've got a wonderful sponsor birch
gold and uh we have the sponsor because
conservatives tend to like some of these
hard assets to diversify their
portfolios so anyway i called up a
friend of ours over at birch gold to
give us his sense of what this means for
the economy
i don't need to tell you that everything
is getting much more expensive and
inflation is hitting record highs and
we're having all sorts of terrible
economic problems so now the fed is
scrambling to hike rates so that they
can try to get this inflation monster
under control and i really don't know
how this is going to work but
fortunately we are joined right now by
someone who does know because because
philip patrick is a birch gold precious
metals specialist you know how much i
love birch gold they're great supporters
of the show and so i figured look i
don't know a damn thing about this topic
so i'm just going to ask
ask someone who actually does thank you
so much sir for coming on the show
thank you very much for having me
michael it's an honor so philip when the
fed announces last week they're going to
hike interest rates by half a percentage
point was that was that an announcement
that you were expecting
yeah
look the the the fed under powell is
probably the most predictable fed we
we've seen in many many years and
they've been telegraphing this half a
percent
rate hike for for quite a while in fact
the treasury market had already priced
it in
and they didn't disappoint of course
we've known for a while that they're
coming because inflation has now become
a political priority for the fed they're
trying to address it and in fact in that
speech powell said that rates need to
now go up expeditiously in order to get
inflation under control so we've got
more rate hikes in front of us between
now and the end of the year i think
they're predicting the federal funds
rate at three percent by the end of the
year so as you'd expect on the back of
news like that the markets are already
starting to suffer i i am glad that i
locked in my mortgage before this
happened but it's still not going to
protect me from all the economic
craziness that's going on at the grocery
store at the gas pump everywhere else so
how do you think this this is going to
play out in the market
well first of all i think it was good
news locking in your mortgage because
rates are now at 13 year highs so that
was a smart move look it's already
starting to unwind this sort of fed
sponsored everything bubble we're
starting to see unwind the markets have
been hit badly this year s p down 16 for
the year so far nasdaq worst start to
the year since the previous financial
crisis in 2008 and even bonds aren't
showing a reprieve the broad bond market
is down 10
uh for for the year to date uh the wall
street journal said it was the worst
bond market since 1842 for a little bit
of context um
yeah um 10-year treasury now close to 3
which again doesn't bode well for the
markets usually the markets perform a
lot better with treasury yields under
three so as i said i think this bubble
is starting to unwind it looks like the
party's over
i'm almost and i i say almost because
it's hard for me to feel sorry for
powell but i'm almost starting to feel
sorry for him because you know he's got
a very difficult challenge it's like
he's trying to land a plane here without
an engine
is it theoretically possible absolutely
that there's a lot of extraneous
circumstances making it difficult for
him we have an executive branch that is
spending money like it's going out of
fashion uh we've got central banks
selling off dollars now to 25 year lows
there's a lot of ways to crash this
plane and only one way to to land it
safely so i think we've got some tough
times ahead unfortunately well that that
is an apt image because what what the
fed wants is to to get a soft landing
and soft landing meaning they avoid some
terrible recession or all sorts of
economic problems so
what do you think the likelihood is of
that
i think it's slim even in in perfect
conditions this soft landing and i could
call it the proverbial soft landing
because i don't think from this
circumstance it's ever been achieved
before um look our best chance i think
is synergy right we need cooperation we
need synergy and an executive branch and
a fed that are working together
but it doesn't seem like we've got that
we've got administration like i
mentioned trying to push through massive
spending packages and what's concerning
is they're not
even being truthful right they were
telling the american people look this is
anti-inflationary it's going to lower
debt and
you know even if they were working hand
in hand like i said it's going to be
difficult but look to break it down we
need to get debt we need to get spending
under control which again not really
happening with biden we need to rebuild
faith in the us dollar as a meaningful
global reserve again but again the
policies they're concerning we're
weaponizing our dollar we're forcing
russia and china now to look for
alternatives which they're doing with
with priority and we need to get
inflation under control and that i think
is going to be hard for for for the fed
too
look they need to raise rates
aggressively to do it right
but they're so concerned about crashing
the markets they're being so sort of
stepping it up but here's the big
problem even if they were to get
aggressive even if powell was to turn
into paul volcker
i'm not sure we can right volca had
rates at 15
the last time inflation was today's
level we can't do that today we've got
30 trillion dollars of national debt
right so if we were to raise rates too
high you know debt service payments
would be not feasible so the chances of
a soft landing here i think it's going
to be very tough so i think people need
to try and look at how they can weather
the storm that's such an important point
with the debt because the only reason
that we can afford all this debt and we
keep taking all of that is because we're
not really paying a whole lot of money
to service it but the minute those rates
go that high then we're in big trouble
so okay so you're saying we need to get
spending under control not going to
happen we need to get debt under control
not going to happen we need we need to
get good fiscal policy that's definitely
not going to happen so
so then i suspect i know your answer to
this i suspect your answer is the same
answer that i would have
what can we do
look uh i i think you do know the answer
but look i i think the key is to
understand the issues which is why shows
like this are so important you keep
people informed and i think once you
understand the issues then the solutions
start to present themselves there was an
interesting quote from the the president
of the national bank of poland and he
summarized why they're buying gold he
said gold is not directly linked to any
nation's economy and can withstand
global unrest in financial markets and
we're seeing it being used russia after
we sort of took them off swift we
destroyed their currency they pegged
their current they pegged oil to gold
prices and of course stabilized the
currency um so we can use it in the same
way look at the nature of our issues we
have currency devaluation we have
inflation we have bubbles in the stock
market as negative as these things are
for people holding stocks and bonds
they're very positive drivers for safe
haven assets like gold and silver
inflation drives them up market
corrections
tend to drive them up so they're
conducive for the climate they're in so
i think for individuals it's just a case
of hedging some of your exposure so that
if we do see broad corrections in the
market we see inflation eroding buying
power at least there's a portion of your
portfolio that can grow in that climate
and mitigate so it's just about
diversification and making sure people
are hedged and as long as you are you
can weather this storm right i i joked
actually when birch gold first came on
the show long time ago i said now i know
that i've made it as a conservative
broadcaster because birch gold has been
a really you know great supporter of uh
conservative shows end of this show but
there's a reason it kind of makes sense
there's a reason why conservatives
generally really like to diversify our
portfolios with gold with silver and
it's because of all the things that
you've just stated so
if you if you want to get a free info
kit no obligation whatsoever text
knowles right now to 98 98 98 something
tells me probably some people now are
kicking themselves and wish that they
texted to get that info kit a few weeks
ago or a few months ago but it's uh it's
not too late just text it right now to
uh knowles to 98 98 98. philip thank you
so much for coming on and helping to uh
clarify this and thank you for
supporting the show
thank you very much for having me
michael
as
andrew clavin likes to quote ernest
hemingway as pointing out things happen
gradually then suddenly and big economic
problems can happen gradually and then
suddenly then all at once that that's
what we're seeing happen right now
probably the craziest story of the day
we don't have time to really get into it
is that there is a baby formula shortage
going on right now not just a minor baby
formula shortage like a really really
big one like uh 40 of all baby formula
products nationwide are currently out of
stock according to data that were
reported by cnn
a lot libs are blaming this on a recall
of products from one plant by this one
group abbot nutrition regardless this is
a huge problem
some people are saying well just have
the mother's breast feed not all mothers
can breastfeed not all babies will latch
and sometimes the supply is not enough
this is an actual acute food problem
this is a starvation problem right now
for the most vulnerable people among us
because of what
it's not just because this one plant
went down it's because of the horrible
economic turmoil that our politicians
foisted on us by shutting down the whole
damn world for a cough for two years and
by disrupting the supply chain which
disproportionately hurts industries such
as baby formula this is a big big
economic problem that's going to have
massive cultural effects and the libs
are calling it a conspiracy theory and
they don't want to talk about it when
people were reporting on this a couple
of weeks ago they said no no fake news
completely ignore it nothing to see here
now we're seeing the real effects what's
going to happen
down the road time to prepare ourselves
time to be serene but firm and and fight
back because because things could get
things could be changing gradually and
then suddenly i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
comes up with an odd label to attack his
political opposition
ultra mega plus the white house
encourages protesters to break the law
by descending on the homes of supreme
court justices and the treasury
secretary is now very much in favor of
abortion help the economy you know
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen